when you go for 62 you have to do the
halftime and the post-game interview
left for tomorrow yeah i got plenty
he's got anything left for tomorrow now
steph when you when you get 62 you have
to do the halftime and the post-game
interview you don't get out of that i
don't mind it
we love talking to you hey tell us about
the 19 free throws that's also a career
best
your mindset of attacking we've seen you
shoot threes your whole life but
really beautiful finishes and taking a
lot of punishment tonight
yeah it's just kind of slowing down
every game we're going to get better and
more so just seeing the pictures of how
they want to defend us
and me individually and get him
get him you see it
yeah he was ready for it though he
wasn't even he didn't jump or anything
he's that's that's how on fire he is you
can't even feel it uh
i don't even know what i was saying but
just shoot shots and
make them and everything kind of opens
up from there just trying to get into
the paint make plays
hey steph are you almost looking forward
to all the double teams and all the
bodies you're going to see because of
how you've mentally prepared
and because of the way you can move
without the ball after you give it up
you can get it back
are you almost looking forward to seeing
all those bodies
not really but it's as long as i can
make the right decision and
yeah you know see the pictures that's
all it is i mean
different shots from years past and a
lot of that is just
not rushing even though there might be
double teams and a crowd
always have options to you know move it
or get a shot or get to the basket
i just got to make sure i see everything
right and i think tonight we just slowed
down a little bit and
it obviously worked out all right how
aware are you of the point total that
you had i mean
you know 54 was the career high coming
in when you get to that
40 spot and things like that or are you
even aware
of the numbers as they're piling up of
course
but you try to just continue to stay
humble and stay
in the moment um that's the the best way
to approach it it doesn't help
when your teammates are yelling at you
every dead ball how many points you got
but other than that it's just don't do
anything differently just keep uh
keep being aggressive um being decisive
and
you know good things happen now when you
had 59
and you were trailing draymond for that
last three why do you got to do clay
like that with his 60
and go for 62 there killer instinct yeah
i mean it it made so much sense that it
was draymond
uh knowing exactly what the situation
was and knowing where i was at
uh for a hot second i thought he wasn't
gonna look for me but
i shouldn't have never doubted it he
knew exactly where i was and thankfully
it went in can you talk about
the way you attacked the room obviously
bob just talked about you getting to the
free throw line but
you're finishing through contact or
making sure you get the foul because
you're jumping into
the defender you're not avoiding contact
at all is that something you thought
about a lot during the off season
a little bit um and again it's kind of
just understanding what the circum
situation is and how they're defending
um and when you have
the right spacing and the right timing
your lanes open up and then
it's just all about finishing i think
you know late in the first half uh
there's a couple plays where they sent a
crowd and i didn't read it right so i
tried to make those
adjustments um and like you said it's
just a matter of
you know finishing with contact being
creative or kicking it out and you've
been pumping iron too i see
you got the arms yeah we had eight
months that's all i could do yeah that's
all you could do
and steph will let you go with this you
had a nice conversation with damian
lillard at the end
his career best 61 came against the dubs
your career best 62 comes against the
blazers
sign me up for lillard curry all night
long i mean you two are just wonderful
to watch and
i know there's always kind of the game
within the game too i mean there's all i
got i said it before
friday's game it's always uh you know
the best guys in the league especially
the point guard position bring the best
out of you and
um if you're around this league long
enough you kind of get to see every kind
of
scenario and situation and um
you know we have a lot to fight for and
a huge challenge in front of us there
you know the established team now so
uh for a guy like him uh like i said it
always just brings the best out of you
and i love the competition
um and that's kind of kind of what it is
bro you got a high audacity level
is there any point in the season where
18 seconds left on shot clock you'll
pull up from half court is that
something that's
maybe gonna happen we'll see
all right steph thanks for stopping man
we appreciate it congrats